[Music]
your mom hit you right relationships in
crisis can be extremely volatile as
witness on couples therapy and those
conflicts are often rooted in years of
family struggles when you suffer your
whole family suffers so now I've turned
my focus to dysfunctional families cut -
hey are you sick in the head where
there's an overbearing mother who
suffocates her adult daughter I got a
look how you a man shut your mouth right
now I swear Tiffany exits we use their
celebrity children as pawns in their own
war poverty cocaine and I didn't do
I don't need that birthday here we go
again just tell me what happened cut
done I know she's just a liar my cross
country a music mogul who refuses to
speak to his own brothers you think it
is that the third you're nothing I can't
talk to a boy I'm not gonna speak to you
if she's calling me a boy you don't know
because you don't speak to me true
sisters could have dealt with teen
pregnancies are struggling to find
common ground so mean they're so
sensitive for an alcoholic whose mother
is afraid for her son's life damn your
we're 35 they're not like grown-ups okay
I just want my kid back cuz I don't know
the guy that turns into a monster
it will kill him your son's life is at
stake
years of suppressed abuse and sadness
will finally be confronted things around
here get intense there was mental and
physical abuse you're a pathological
liar he doesn't want to hear what really
but that on the freight sales funds and
emotions will spiral out of control that
just feels like I just got a shot and my
team and I are in for the fight of our
lives be stupid and don't be acting coy
with me which is why anger management
specialists dr. Christian Ponte would be
by my side believing me Liam no I'm
leaving I can't even look at her she is
evil in no way shape or form was a
healthy or effective you know you've got
to learn to change a lifetime of pain
won't be healed overnight I think you've
been carrying a lot the truth hurts
my kid's name is on there and that's
never happening but with hard work I'm
hoping to put an end to these family of
Units
I don't mean to hurt you I need you what
you're doing here
this is how you heal
family therapy new series premieres
Wednesday March 16th at 9:00 only on vh1
[Music]